good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-2460
object class
ketter
previously safe
special containment procedures
due to its position and properties
scp-2460 is not contained at this time
space agencies are to be informed of
scp-2460's trajectory so that satellites
and launches do not collide with
scp-2460 when doing so
scp-2460 is to be listed as a large
piece of space debris no object is
allowed within 50 kilometers of scp-2460
any matter colliding with
scp-2460 must be reported to the
astronomical tracking unit at site 195
immediately in the event of a collision
the mass density and schwarzschild
radius of scp-24c
must be re-measured and its resulting
new orbital trajectory calculated
description
scp-2460 is a gravitational anomaly in
elliptical orbit around the earth it has
an orbital period of 4 hours with a
furthest distance from the surface of
the earth of 12 430 kilometers and a
closest approach of 395 kilometers
measurement of the gravitational anomaly
indicates it has a mass of 1.24 times 10
to the power of 13 kilograms at the
location of the anomaly there is an
apparent object of approximately 50 by
30 by 15 meters this gives the object a
measured density of 5.51 times 10 to the
power of 8 kilograms meters squared
which is approximately 100 000 times the
density of the earth and close to the
density of a white dwarf star
the shape of this object is variable in
appearance with components of different
materials appearing to erupt from the
surface of the object only to be
reabsorbed furthermore the object is
virtually invisible to electromagnetic
radiation and has no measurable charge
magnetic moment or wave emissions
however despite this behavior photons in
the visible light spectrum still
interact with the object albeit at a low
albedo of 0.01
the anomaly behaves very differently on
the quantum level
scp-2460 is comprised of bosonic matter
that anomalously maintains much of the
structure of fermionic or normal matter
this anomalous construction causes the
poly exclusion principle not to apply
allowing non-matter to occupy the same
quantum state as other similarly
composed bosonic matter in addition
electromagnetic interaction is
suppressed as a result the bosonic
electron fields between objects in
scp-2460 do not repel each other
the net result of these anomalous
quantum effects is that multiple
individual objects within
scp-2460 occupy the same place at the
same time what appears to be objects
growing out of and receding into
scp-2460
is actually thousands of co-locating
objects oscillating about the
gravitational center of the anomaly the
exceptionally high mass of scp-2460
is the result of these thousands of
individual objects occupying the same
location all gravitationally bound
together
it is important to note that this
co-location is not spatiotemporal
distortion but the net result of the
lack of interaction between individual
objects in the anomaly there is no risk
of a reversion to a euclidean space
because the space is already euclidean
the influence of the gravitation of
thousands of objects acts as a strange
attractor keeping each individual object
within 105 meters of the center of
scp-2460 at all times the chaotic nature
of the attractor has caused multiple
objects to be shown at the surface of
scp-2460 at different intervals most of
the items expressed are space dust and
rocky debris similar in composition to
asteroids the following items are
notable however
a planetesimal with the above dimensions
of 50 by 30 by 15 meters this item acts
as the surface of scp-2460
of note is the distinct lack of
cratering on the surface
a comet nucleus of approximately 5
meters in diameter visible spectral
analysis suggests that the object's
original location was the oort cloud
a space-faring vessel of unknown make 10
meters in length the hall is covered
with unidentified symbols through a
plate glass window two beings are
visible apparently long deceased and
desiccated resembling crocodilian
humanoids
approximately 1 000 metric tons of
hydrogen and helium compressed under
gravitation into a super fluid state
90 capsules each containing a single
humanoid occupant each co-locating
independently from the others the
occupants are apparently dead and
desiccated
foundation probe ou 113 and agent rick
roberts deceased see addendum 2460b
addendum 2460 a
on 2 15 2013 a stray orbiting steel bolt
attached to a retaining plate from the
disaster was seen to be captured by the
gravity well and collide with scp-2460
it was observed that the collision
caused no impact sight and the bolt
passed through the matter without
hindrance however post-collision the
bolt and plate no longer registered any
electromagnetic field deformation
further observation demonstrated that
the bolt remains attached to the plate
confirming that the co-location effect
of items caught within the anomaly does
not extend to items that are exposed
within milliseconds to it
this observation further suggests that
all objects seen in
scp-2460 were at one time normal
fermionic matter transformed by the
anomaly into the presently seen
amalgamation it is hypothesized that the
anomaly annihilates the quantum spin of
the subatomic particles transforming the
matter from fermionic to bosonic and
allowing it to co-locate containment
procedures updated to prevent further
matter collisions with scp-2460
further testing is suggested
addendum 2460 b
on o205 2014
scp-2460 was noted to pass within 70
kilometers of foundation orbital unit 11
and a sortie was authorized to intercept
the anomaly for quantum measurements
agent rick roberts was sent into probe
ou113 to examine the anomaly at close
range for testing of the quantum
signature of the matter within the
object radio contact with probe ou113
ceased when the probe came within 5
kilometers of the central mass
approximately 0.5 seconds before loss of
contact apparent density of the low
earth orbit medium seen to increase from
1.0 times 10 to the power of minus 11
kilograms per meter cubed to 7.3 times
10 to the power of -9 kilograms per
meter cubed
all remaining data from the experiment
comes from the cameras aboard orbital
unit 11. agent roberts quickly noted the
lack of radio contact and engaged
thrusters to maneuver away from scp-2460
the fuel was seen to ignite and pass
ineffectually through the hull and cabin
of probe ou113 unable to adjust position
or trajectory probe ou113 was
gravitationally captured by scp-2460
and fell into the central mass
fifteen thousand five hundred and
thirty-four kilograms added to the mass
of scp-2460
trajectory and schwarzschild radius
recalculated containment procedures
updated to include a mandatory distance
of 50 kilometers
addendum 2460 c
transcriptive lecture regarding scp-2460
on 4 3 2015.
presenter
dr cornelius argent
principal researcher astronomical
phenomena division
forward
dr c argent presents the results of his
observations and experiments with
scp-2460
begin log
good evening and welcome i want to thank
everyone for coming this evening tonight
i'm going to explain what exactly
scp-2460 is and the risk it represents
for the earth
i could explain the fermion to boson
conversion called quantum spin
annihilation explain how this
interaction is possible under a version
of supersymmetry the transformation of
quarks to squawks and so on but i'm sure
that will go over most of your heads you
could learn it all but you're here to
understand what this is and what it
means i'll spare you the physics i'm
sure you've heard stories of walking
through walls ghosts radio waves certain
anomalies etc phasing is a popular term
for it
in essence
scb-2460 is a collection of objects
asteroids comets nebular material
stellar mass and more all phasing around
each other it's important to recognize
that this phasing is the sole reason all
these objects exist in the same place at
the same time this is not a
spatio-temporal distortion at least not
anything more than is fully and
non-anonymously explainable by its
gravity alone
however what is less explainable is the
lack of electromagnetic interaction
within scp-2460
firstly this means that there is no
radio communication possible with
anything within the anomaly radio waves
pass through it as if it wasn't there
this is also what leads to the phasing
effect we see you know how we are made
of atoms and atoms consist of a nucleus
surrounded by an electron cloud
these electron clouds are negatively
charged and push each other away
and that's why we can't walk through
walls
but within
scp-2460 the electron fields between
objects introduced at separate times
don't interact don't push against each
other and as a result don't stop objects
from passing through one another
but wait you're probably asking isn't
the photon the gauge boson for the
electromagnetic interaction why do we
see anything
okay you're likely not asking that but i
did first thing truth is
we don't see most of scp-2460
experiment 2460b proved that we saw the
medium density around probe ou113
increase nearly a thousand fold before
losing contact there is a cloud of
massive particles that have nearly no
interaction with normal matter extending
as far as five kilometers from the
central mass there are only two ways
these particles interact gravitationally
and rendering normal matter that comes
into contact with it out of phase these
particles are invisible and otherwise
undetectable all remaining mass was
added subsequently acting as an anchor
for the particles that's why we can see
the massive object in the center
what's the risk from this well it is
exponentially dense and thus
perturbations from its present orbit
will preferentially cause the orbit to
decay resulting in
scp-2460 falling to earth now since it
remains phased out collision with the
earth won't cause any impact crater
however the quantum spin annihilation
will affect all matter the anomaly
passes through resulting in invisible
holes of phased out ground
scp-2460 will pass unhindered through
the center of the earth transforming
matter the entire way leaving a giant
hole through the center of the earth
that the liquid mantle and core will
gush into the crust and surface
eventually falling unsupported into the
hole
but it won't end there the momentum in
scp-2460 will propel it all the way back
out of the center of the earth back to
the surface where it will
gravitationally oscillate back and forth
back and forth rendering more and more
of the earth out of phase with itself
like swiss cheese until the entire
planet collapses into a central super
dense pile of untouchable rubble
constituting a qk-class quantum
degeneracy end-of-the-world
scenario
so
i'm sure you agree that we want this
thing as far away from us as possible
the problem is we can't touch it we
can't use thrusters to push it away
there's nothing to push against we can't
deflect it with magnetic fields there's
no electromagnetic interaction we can
only use gravity to pull it away
that means that we will need to tow an
asteroid of similar mass into low earth
orbit to carefully slingshot the anomaly
away from us then destroy the asteroid
somehow
an asteroid approximately 22 kilometers
in diameter should contain enough mass
to eject the anomaly recommendations
have been submitted to our five command
but i'm sure you actually are all asking
what is this and why did it end up here
orbiting around the earth
well it's an amalgamation of weakly
interacting massive particles invisible
to electromagnetic radiation emitting no
radiation of its own
and possessing only gravity
in short ladies and gentlemen scp-2460
is dark matter
and when you consider that fully 85
of the mass in the universe is dark
matter we should not ask why we are so
unlucky to have a chunk of it orbiting
around the earth we should ask why are
we so lucky that we haven't hit any of
this stuff yet
thank you and good evening
end log
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you are all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
zargaran
the morrigan
professor puffer
retalias
your local fish man
derivative
talk of villagers
gabriel hawkins
nate decline
lost boy
african submarine vore
seventy
kristoff kozak slesak
hms lily
the almighty fish
gav the clumsy containment specialist
pure osmium
scio dio demnatus
brian sanchez
matthew gilmore
eric corbin
longinus
james saba
and
nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash thevogen
thank you
you